this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
january 31st and from the heart of
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
in two weeks it's the moment we've been
waiting for since [__] september
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of super bowl 56 is
giving you
56 to one odds on either team for the
super bowl you bet the fin fight owls to
get 280 and free bets if your team wins
draftkings sportsbook is now live in new
york meaning you can bet from almost a
third of the country if sportsbook isn't
in your state yet listen draftkings
daily fantasy is tremendous
new customers can get a shot at one
million dollars top prize with their
first
deposit download the draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code joey
to get 56 to one odds on either team you
bet five dollars and you win 280 if your
team wins that promo code joey
get 56 to one odds at draftkings book
and official sports betting partner of
super bowl 56 now you got to be 21 or
older minimum age and location
requirements vary by jurisdiction this
ain't law and order but we got to do
what we got to do
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details and requirements
and state-specific responsible gaming
resources void we're prohibited now if
you got a gaming problem call 1-800
gamble you know the deal if you're in
tennessee call the tn red line
1-800-889-9789
if you're in connecticut it's
if you're in new 888-789-7777 and you
got a problem call
800 no 8778
hope new york but if you don't have a
problem it's time to make some [__]
getters with draftking sportsbook get
the dra the the
[__]
profit boost we're going deep
that's it and that's that download it
you want to make money the super bowl
stop crying
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion
i've been on the capsules lately jesus
christ the milk chocolate's tremendous
the dark chocolates were tremendous
which is required little dark chocolate
never killed nobody cbd line is [__]
tremendous i've been telling you guys
for three years and i'm going to tell
you again today on a monday if you got
to show the pain whatever you got
cbd lion will help you go to cbdlion.com
right now read the third party lab
results and what they have available to
you from the back balls to the tape
to the roll-on cream to just the superb
cream that i put on my knees every night
i even put some on my face
nothing happens when i put on my face
but i get moisturized that's cbd lion
read
learn
third party lab results you like
something press in joey join
and get 20 off delivered right to your
house and don't forget those gummies
from cbd lion it's monday [__] let's
get this party started
there you go
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here monday my favorite day
of the week the 31st of january it's
[__] over that's it the beginning of
the year blues you know listen january's
let's get be honest january's
usually suck dick
nobody can make a decision
they don't know because nothing really
happens till [__] february 14th
that's when people come out of that coma
you know they get that credit card bill
like right now people getting their
[__] credit card bill from christmas
they're getting a weird [__]
surprise you know that's what happens so
now most people like [__] it i'm waiting
for my tax return tax return are you
kidding me you know unless you do the
[__] quick tax or whatever the [__]
but anyway
but now that's it february is a little
better you got over your little
[__] uh
you said you're gonna lose 50 pounds
three days in you ate a chocolate cake
[__] it now we know where we stand
and that's it it's february first
[__] tomorrow the best thing about
february first
not that the renters do but the best
thing about february first is ice cream
shop my little beautiful [__]
up there in studio city are releasing
the like they're doing like
what's that movie that [__] uh what's
his name man six degrees of separation
right
so okay so we came up with the cocoa
weed right but what they want to do is
under the laughing gas banner
is release like three or four other
brands
that are [__] tremendous the one
that's getting released tomorrow
is a brand called white truffle you get
it up at ice cream shop and i got two
other places that are gonna have it i'll
mention to you
uh i'll [__] put it on twitter or
some [__] just to let you know we got a
couple different smoke shops so
tomorrow is white truffle me personally
i don't have any on me because i smoked
it that's why i don't have any the last
time i had an eighth of it was probably
the beginning of december
and it is [__] strong it's [__]
pretty and it does not [__] around
then they're going to release a
different cocoa than a [__] sashimi
or some [__] but anyway you put it all
these weeds are going to [__] knock
you the [__] down we got the hybrid we
got the [__] sativa we got the indica
so all be within the laughing gas label
[Music]
this is a little bag just to make it
official to let you [__] know
how we do it so you're walking down the
street like joe la bomba with your
little [__]
weed bag you can't do that now in
california because some of you'll
[__] pull over
take that [__] from you but this
is the new laughing gas
this is the new
uh bags the laughing gas
same reefer
same [__] quality trust me
and uh just a little cool little [__]
package we're gonna be getting the
t-shirts and the hoods here you go
brother
and then the edible of the week you know
listen it's monday morning i like to
start the week
right off the [__] box okay if
you don't think i smoke dope this
morning out of your [__] mind i can't
do it no more i do my [__] in the
morning i wash my [__] breakfast mercy
goes on the [__] bus
and after i get a little woken up see in
l.a what i was doing is i wasn't even
awake
and i was smoking tembong it's that's
not bueno no wonder you need coffee in
an hour that's not bueno that's not
civilized it's not [__] human
so now it's nice and easy you see what
i'm saying when i get up
during the week now
i get up i go outside regardless of what
the [__] temperature is i'm out there
with my cup of coffee
some days i could stand some days
there's snow on my chair you know what
i'm saying
i can't sit but most of the time i just
sit and i look i sit out there for about
10-15 minutes
and i tell the world i'm [__]
grateful i'm grateful for what i got and
now nobody's going to take it from me
today i'm grateful for where i'm at
today i say all that [__] you know just
to remind yourself that you don't go
[__] nuts
i look into the trees in the wilderness
i thank god for giving me another day
i touch my [__] balls i finish my cup
of coffee and i come downstairs i gotta
do [__] in the morning i gotta write
journals and [__] but after all that's
done i eat my breakfast
i go upstairs it's about [__] eight
o'clock
now it's about 7 45 by now i wash my
little monkey
i eat my breakfast just two eggs with
the piece of wheat toast it's quick i
just eat the yolks if you think i'm
gonna sit there and regurgitate those
[__] whites you're out of your
[__] mind and then
i start my [__] day and then at about
9 30 10
is when i hit the pipe of life
maybe two maybe three little bong hits
on the [__] pipe from uh
the freeze pipe and uh that [__] sets me
off to like five or six in the afternoon
there's no more [__] smoking at one
two and guess what i get my daily
requirements and i smoke at like ten i'm
smoked before it's two o'clock
my vitamins are good i got some [__]
oil in the joints and we're ready to go
but it's monday morning who the [__] are
you kidding if we're gonna be ready to
go i got these sent to me
they're at uh
they're at uh tommy chung's my man i
love him to death he's got cannabis
infused
premium thc strips
chocolate mint
me and mike will have to do a couple you
know what i'm saying mike's got to drive
home in the snow
let him play bumper cars if he wants who
gives a [__]
it's tremendous i like all this stuff i
like when they put the reefer in the
[__] packaging and this is very neat
it's very well done
these are your not the original breath
strips i don't know what happened to
that company but when the medical
marijuana hit la
there were these [__] bread strips
that would knock your dick in the dirt
and i would always make mistakes
because you don't put them in your pho
the good thing i like about this is you
don't put in your [__] wallet
you could put it in your wallet
see the other ones came in like a baggie
and then you took them out and you put
them in your [__] wallet
you know so when you're ready to go like
a condom you never know when you're
ready to go right you go into a [__]
classroom it's kind of boring you're
like you know what i'll drop a 50
milligram strip these are just tense
i had two of them the other day it says
10 servings
that's 100 this one
a hundred that's what i
[Music]
[__] it
we might as well do two you know i'm
saying it's that type of monday it's the
31st we got to celebrate the ending of
the [__] january we did it we pushed
through snow blizzards
[Music]
shovels let me tell you something
i was watching that snowstorm
since [__] uh
friday night
it started snowing friday in the day
like they're like well get ready for
eight o'clock the snow's about to come
down [__]
it was coming down at eight o'clock
friday [__] morning i swear to god
there was snow already coming down it
wasn't sticking
but it was [__] coming down with a
vengeance jack and then it stopped
and then about
just when they listened
my love goes out i love weather people
because they're always [__] wrong but
they are they really are you got to work
with them dog like i told you before the
weather is a [__] uh what do you call
that word is a hypothesis which is an
educated guess
it's like when you buy
sports information
from my man stu final who's one of the
best in the [__] business when you
buy sports information from him
it's a hypothesis
you understand me but he's been in the
game for 50 [__] years so if you're
going to take advice from somebody
it's from him when i see a 22 year old
like a 29 year old or 30 year old
weatherman suck my dick you're not gonna
tell me no no i don't know i love these
people who look on their phones to see
what the weather is whatever happened
with opening up the [__] window
looking outside i'll tell you what it's
like it's cold [__] it's january
and jersey which means take a [__]
hooded sweatshirt
just in case it gets cold if it gets
warm you can put the sweatshirt around
your [__] waist and walk around like
axel rose on the [__] uh
87 tour you know what i'm saying the one
where they did live at the ritz remember
you had the white shirt with the [__]
sweatshirt around
[__] you axel was a bad [__] now
he looks worse than i do that
[__] looks like he ate 10
cheeseburgers and never looked back but
he could still [__] sing anyway it's
monday morning we ain't gonna just do
one you know what i'm saying we gotta
hit this [__] with a duke
because that's how we do it here at the
uncle joey's joint why call it the
[__] joint correct for a long time i
gave you guys a little [__] breather
we were getting our head together but
now our heads together the goals are
intact
so you got to cut it up from time to
time
[__] trimming december little
chocolate mint
[__] cheech and
always putting things down is that 100
milligrams are you [__] sure
we blocked
yeah
yeah that's what i said to you there's
10 in there
and there's one two three four
i ate two you ate two that's eight and i
ate two the online so there you go i got
40 milligrams left obviously these
things are like
it's like going to a restaurant ordering
an appetizer
and the appetizer comes like when you
get a shrimp cocktail and you got like
five shrimp cocktails this is like
eating two out of five you know what i'm
saying
it ain't gonna do nothing for you but at
least you had it it's in the blood
system and hopefully later on i haven't
been [__] killing the edibles but
i will tell you one thing
you know people hit me up all the time
some [__] joker the other night
said get joey better [__] edibles
time to go [__] himself
these [__] stupid people
you know abx
is my number one go-to edible
why do i know because
myself
and many people have had heart attacks
on them you know we don't need edibles
to jump up and down and get in a conga
circle you know with our friends with
dirty feet that's not what we eat
we eat [__] edibles to be like this
whether with headphones on or in front
of the tv that's why i eat edibles if
you think i eat edibles to you know
go to [__] fuego man whatever fireman
and hang out with people and drink
[__] from chicks titties that just
had a kid [__] yeah burning man
that's not what i want to do at all i
want to [__] do an edible and just be
like this
whether it's in the front seat of my car
not driving whether it's on my couch
whether it's on the chair i just want to
be [__] stoned
nobody has put more people under the
trenches than abx edibles
everybody has called me with their saga
and their story
the stars of death also had a tremendous
reputation
[__] wherever owen benjamin lives
that stars don't even come out at night
that [__] will never want to see
a star again so we've been through some
[__] edibles i'm very experienced i
enjoy going down i've puked a couple
times tremendous
you don't know it's like when you do
heroin you got to puke a little that's
it'll let you know it's good when you
puke an edible you have [__] arrived
and let me tell you something there's
different colors to the puke of an
edible if you puke white
you got to puke green mixed with a
little blood that's when you [__] at
eureka you're insane i'm only kidding
you about the blood there's a lot of
people watching right now going blood oh
my god we were late no there's no blood
coming out of nowhere it's just a joke
people
but uh
bro when you puked the green stuff from
a [__] edible that's
i remember on that old uh
the [__]
banana bread with the chocolate chips
and that [__]
let me tell you something guys i think
well that was also the beginning
of the [__] going to see the devil
like that was putting out the beginning
was
uh
kushmart
had the
the [__] salt and taffy whatever that
[__] thing was
that would put you over
that [__] uh
no milligram brownie
gave me that
restless leg syndrome you have breath
you know these people you have restless
leg syndrome dog
don't take the edibles from kushmart i
was on a [__] plane from l.a to
pittsburgh and my [__] legs i
was sitting in the back and my [__]
legs are like that dancer whatever his
name is just name a dancer who moves
quickly that's how my legs are i'm
fatter than the [__] and i'm sitting
there with a half a [__] united blanket
on me and my legs are [__] bouncing
that's the worst reaction you get to the
edible and i'll be honest with you the
last time i did one of those
987 milligram tubes
that happened to be through that night
that's the last time i touched those
tubes one night i made the [__] tea
of death and i put that tube in that
[__] and dog my legs were
bouncing i couldn't even fall asleep i
was tired but my legs kept [__]
bouncing and i felt like when you ever
see one of those puppets when they pull
your [__] legs up i swear to god
i was falling asleep and i could see my
legs
bouncing so i don't advise those edibles
i don't like that feeling i like to see
the devil i like to have my mouth open
if i feel a little drool so be it then
you really did something good but the
edibles i prefer the most abx to see the
devil
and i'm gonna tell you which ones i
picked up in jersey
that will kill you
they will kill you i have never giggled
that much
the other night i ate 300 milligrams
a true dose edibles
that is little tiny [__] gummy bears
they don't look like [__]
i picked them up about six weeks ago and
i went to a party like not a party i
went to a football party at gyms
and there's two professionals over there
and we don't smoke when we're at jimmy's
nobody smokes over there so
i gave my boy
i tested as i gave them both they're 15
milligrams i mean they're the tiniest
[__]
gummy bear you'll ever see in your life
great flavors they got coca-cola
pineapple they don't [__] around over
that true dose
it looks like a wallet it comes in a
little box that looks like a wallet
and you open it up and it has a baggie
inside similar to this and you [__]
don't even bother trying to open it just
cut the [__] with a scissors
that's why when you open it make sure
you're going down deep and you got the
soldiers there with you like if you're
gonna if you don't like going deep i'm
gonna tell you something
[Music]
if you eat
45 milligrams so the true dose
edibles
it's like eating
[__]
200 i mean it will [__] you up
the first time i came up on them i gave
two of them one to a friend of mine one
to one buddy and one to the other one i
swear to god these guys are loud like me
and obnoxious and they [__] crack
jokes
i was sitting there like oh these
[__] haven't said a word like
15 minutes i looked over at them
both their eyes were [__] chinese i
mean they were like this and i asked the
one guy hey how you doing he goes
uh and i was like holy [__] these guys
have been smoking dope for 40 years
they're in their 50s they're in my age
they've been smoking dope for 40 years
both of them were [__] lit when i
mean they didn't say a word for an hour
then you know how an edible slips up on
you it eases up the [__] headlock a
little bit it eased it up and then they
were like they started eating chicken
wings and potato chips and going to the
bathroom i asked them how are those
[__] edibles they're like tremendous
so i had 300 milligrams minus 30 is 270.
i said [__] it take a chance columbus
did let's see if they do me and these
things are [__] tremendous they did
these two savages in
with 15 they're gonna [__] me up so i
dropped the whole bag at them there's no
looking back i just opened it and tipped
my head and the whole chunk came out
cause that sometimes if you're lucky the
gummies get together they melt together
in your pocket
dog
i was [__]
the water went down the wrong tube
the water went down the wrong tube it's
that happens i'm sorry about that
dog i ate those 270 milligrams and i was
[__] up
and about a week late i called
and got like two more of those boxes
because that's all i could get
and i because they're pretty pricey
but
they had a sale
and i caught the [__] sale
and they only had a couple coca-colas i
didn't like the kiwi i don't like the
kiwi flavor
holy [__] i think
tuesday night maybe tuesday or wednesday
night if
monday had to be like tuesday night i
[__] ate a whole bag just about six
o'clock
i got back from kickboxing with mercy
and i'm like you know what nothing's
crackalacking tonight i'm just gonna
watch a couple [__] episodes of a y
and get [__] up
i ate the whole box about six o'clock
dog by 9 30. i couldn't stop [__]
giggling
i called lee and tortured him a little
bit
and [__]
i called a friend of mine and tortured
him
there's a dude on facebook
that's been hit me up
i gotta say for like a [__] year i
don't know what the kid's name is he's a
nice kid
but he started hitting me up when i was
moving in the process of moving
you know and i
he hit me up and he goes hey i'm doing
this podcast can you come on like a dog
i'm in the process of moving right now
hit me up in like you know four or five
months when you say that to people
they disappear
i you know i explained them i was moving
that i i would be more than willing to
help him out but i was moving so i
forgot all about it this [__]
starts hitting me up
about i don't know
like last
september
he's like joey you know i haven't
listened to the podcast but i know you
probably settled and stuff
but it was still when i was going
to the tail end of my [__] it was like
the beginning of september i said dog
listen
i'm living on [__] zoom now
i hate [__] doing zoom you know i got
to do them for these i mean there's no
other way for right now
but for right now give me a breather
with the [__] zooms i don't really
want to do any zoom podcast i mean i'm
just
unless it's like uh sickler which i like
to do this week i mean i was supposed to
do this girls last week but the [__]
snowstorm [__] it all up for us
you know i really unless i really know
you i don't but if i don't know you a
zoom is not going to work it's not going
to work unless i'm in studio or
something
so you know
doggy hits me up i gotta tell you every
day
and we do the podcast today and i've
noticed that there's something wrong
with him
he's like can we do the podcast today
can we do the podcast and i just hit him
with thumbs up
and you know this has been going on
since [__] like november
so there's only one person who
understands this and that's
so that night i thought about it i'm
like lee you're not going to believe
this that dude is still hitting me up
for the podcast and i just keep giving
him thumbs up and he's like so what does
this mean and i'm like
jesus christ you can't be this [__]
dumb like he just
you know like give it a breather once we
go back to [__] regular
living without people being i mean the
numbers are going down thank god oh
that's what they're telling us this week
who the [__] knows just live your life
if they want you to wear a mess you put
it on if not i [__] i don't give a
[__] anymore we've been breathing cocked
air and [__] you ever go to a you
know i was thinking about that the other
day like when you're a kid i used to go
to 42nd street some people were talking
about the old times square
i'm like if you went in there and
breathe i'm surprised we're not [__]
pregnant
through air
whatever like if you get pregnant from
sucking dick in the air or some [__]
you'd walk into those places you gotta
assume that there's 30 guys jerking off
at one time and those [__] pee-wee
hubs you know those pee-wee herman hubs
whatever the [__] you call them and
you're in there walking around looking
for change for tokens that that sperm's
got to release some toxic [__] air
and nobody ever died in those [__]
places so it's like i don't even know
what i'm talking about but you guys know
what i'm saying if you you know for
years you breathe all this [__] and now
you gotta wear [__] masks it just
don't make sense to me either but i do
what they tell me what am i gonna do if
it makes life easier for the guy next to
me but you guys know where i stand with
this [__] every week
is a new [__] adventure i'm through
with it i'm just moving on to smoking
dope in the daytime not giving a [__]
and whatever happens happens you do your
[__]
push-ups you write your goals you eat
your carrots
and that's it you're ready to [__] go
what are you scared about if you die
that's it what are you going to live for
[__] ever tell me the truth you want
to be betty white 99 years old your
[__] closes up you have problems [__]
and nobody wants to bang you you you're
walking around you got to take 8 000
medications so before you want to live
to 100 you better it's better want than
to have a wise old man told me that it's
better to want
than to have
that's it i don't know what else to
[__] tell you obviously this [__]
20 milligram put a jolt
to me i'm feeling [__] great right
now
uh i was telling mike the [__] and i'm
telling you guys shoveling snow is a
[__] savage
you know when they tell you like if
you're over 50 don't go out there and
shovel snow what are you gonna do
wait for a kid to walk and knock on your
door those [__] aggressive kids have
disappeared nobody knocked on my door
saying hey mister you want to give us 30
bucks if we shovel your thing not one
[__] person it's it's unreal that
that whole generation
[__] disappeared yesterday was a big
[__] money day for me when i
was a kid in north bergen [__]
[__]
with all those [__] hills we would
get our [__] done as soon as snow i
think this [__] started with a listen i
never i never even knew there was living
in snow those jersey kids don't make a
living out of [__] anything that's
why i give them credit i swear to god
when i was a kid
if you didn't hustle as a kid you fell
the [__] behind it didn't matter that
you played football or wrestled or got
a's
you had to make [__] cash when i was
a kid unless i'm you're not gonna
[__] get become a millionaire but i
knew kids that became [__]
really successful and had a start at
life
from the money they made just between
the newspaper routes
between the [__] shoveling snows and
shoveling cars
between i knew a kid what the [__] was
his name i grew up and lived in charles
court this [__] bought a
lawnmower when he was like [__] 12
and he would just huff you know
everybody else is jumping up and down
smoking dub
let's party this i used to even like
i never tortured him but i goofed on him
a little bit dog did you what do you do
with all this money and he goes i'm
putting it away for a car well guess
what
at 17 i think his parents told me they
were gonna give him a 3 000 budget
he showed up at like four or five that
he put away from cutting [__] lawns
and they had to match it so he ended up
putting a down pay i mean that's [__]
crazy i couldn't even put two nickels
together when i was [__] 17. i didn't
have no money that i'd save the money i
had in the bank was a number i hit on my
birthday in 1979
that's the only money i had put away and
after my mother died i spent it but i
had like
i gotta say i had like five friends
[__] jimmy lebrano put himself
through [__] college
pumping gas
till this day
i love them with all my [__] heart we
haven't smoked in a few months but i got
the utmost respect at that age i
couldn't put anything together i
couldn't even pay a [__] rent that
was 100 a [__] month never mind a
college bill i don't even know how to
fill out a [__] college belt but
that's one thing about growing up in
jersey dog all the winters
and i went around with the car yesterday
and drove around
there was not one [__] kid out if
they're not sledding they ain't out
they're inside playing computers or
whatever the [__] they play
but man when it snowed in my neighbor
when i was a kid
we were out of the house by eight
[__] am
knocking on people's door every 15
minutes you hear beep beep beep you
gotta go help a guy
dog we wouldn't [__] touch your car
until we saw cash
we were ruthless
it was like me sabatino speciale
the young micah anthony got arrested so
there was like eight of us that would
just hang out on union turnpike
and just wait for [__] to get
stuck
and we tell them how much to pull this
out
10 bucks 10 bucks that's too much what's
your option
you see anybody else walking on these
[__] streets you better dig deep in
that pocket for that ten dollar bill
we'll move on to the old lady down the
corner and doug that's the way it was
all day we just pushed push push and we
push and [__] would fall nobody
ever got hit by a car it was tremendous
and we all went home with 50 to 80
[__] dollars this is 40 years ago
guys
sometimes we had a hundred dollars maybe
on my newspaper route
i was making a half a yard a week that's
[__] insane
for a kid
at that age 1977
1976 i was a [__] geek at that time
once they listened the great bill hicks
once said
smoking bot don't make it [__] lazy
it just makes you realize that what
you're gonna do ain't worth it you know
what i'm saying
that's what the that's what the great
bill hicks once said and i stuck with it
that's a tremendous joke he used it on
uh
not the rodney special yeah it could
have been the rodney special well he
said listen smoking weed because he went
off on [__] who smoke weed and
jump out a window and all that [__] he's
like you dumb [__] you're
[__] up for all of us
which is stupidity and all that [__] but
it really is the truth that [__]
if
you know sometimes you smoke weed you
know i'm not going down there
that's what he said he goes i'm not
gonna go down and
[__] sweep i don't need to do that
[__]
but it's a [__] truth like sometimes
you get high and you're like
it's not gonna [__] happen i'm not
gonna go down there
but at that age man we hustled off and
listen i got none against the youth of
america today they're all gonna be able
to [__] fire a missile
from their living room when they're
[__] 18 including my daughter i don't
know what they do on that phone all day
or what they do on that [__] computer
i look over her shoulders playing
[__] games and stuff we cut out the
youtube [__]
you could not watch [__] uh
youtube and she wanted to put up her own
page she can't handle kids saying you
suck
she's too young for that you know she's
too [__] young for that i wanna so
like i didn't even know i had my
friend's kid he said something about tic
toc and i asked the dad he's got a tick
tock and he goes dog
he's got a tick tock but it's the light
one
they can't see
remarks or you can't see comments you
disable the [__] comments for the
kids me i don't give a [__] what you're
writing the [__] comments you're the
one that's watching and [__] i don't
give a [__] and like i told you guys
those comments to me
i mean you know guns and roses that's
when i knew like listen i and i knew
before this
but when you look at guns and roses is
it november rain wasn't it the first
video they had a billion
it's like the now they have two of them
conjuring rose is the first band
to have two videos that have hit over a
billion likes
but if you go on a billion likes go look
at it this is how you know it's real
there's
i don't know
a million dislikes
so when you look at november rain and
you go wow
i mean to me that's some of guns and
roses best [__] is use your illusion one
and two
they really morphed into each other they
were [__] great those two albums
when i see that that there's a million
dislikes well first of all
they got a billion [__] likes so a
million don't even put a dent in your
car
but you think about it a [__]
million dislikes
who the [__] are these people what do
you listen to banjo music or something
you don't like november rain and the
other one that they have
is also a great one and there's times i
watched like whenev for a long time i
don't do it anymore
but for a long time when i was learning
the computer i would go on there and put
on youtube videos and it'd be a great
band
it'd be like somebody [__] great like
alice in change rotten apple or
something
and they'd be like you know
they have uh 800 000 likes
and you still got 100 000 people and if
you read the comments oh my god
you know this is great music you know
[__] whatever his name was was great
and then it's like [__] just
attacking them you're heroin
[__] you should all died and
i'm like
if you take this [__] seriously
then there's something [__] wrong
with you you know right now
it's really interesting because on the
album of the week on patreon right now
i just cut like a big gap out because
from 87
i mean like before i got locked up i
wasn't really listening to anything
solid it was white snake that was good
that white snake was doing something
def leopard pour some sugar on me
whatever that album was i don't know if
it's hysteria i don't know
i was listening to like then when i got
locked up the big albums were
guns and roses you know uh
the first one whatever sweet child of
mine all that [__] appetite for
destruction
bobby brown don't be cruel was a huge
[__] hit in prison tremendous great
[__] album
great [__] song uh
brothers went nuts when we put that on
so the bikers and the white dudes listen
to guns and roses
the brothers listen to a lot of bobby
brown and uh
i don't know oh too short
too short is that his name too short or
there was a girl her name was lena suck
my dick with a bottle of win you know
it was too short yeah too short out of
oakland
too short they listen to that stuff they
listen to
what was the other jam they listened to
in there i forget what their
for the love of francis
i forget the name of that band there was
a lot of like light technical stuff
there was really nothing solid
and then when i got out of jail and got
into the halfway house there was these
white dudes at the halfway house and one
day i don't know they were listening to
[__]
pearl jam or some [__] it sounded okay
you know and
i don't know i was still into black
sabbath and all my stupidity to be
honest i was just listening to the
[__]
i was just doing coke you know i was
just busy doing coke trying to get my
life together i wasn't really
you know reading cream magazine or
rolling stone anymore and evolved from
that [__] but
the first time i woke up from my drug
coma was
93 and i would watch mtv at a sony
trinitron
and that's all i did was watch mtv you
know and
eventually this came on you know
jeremy and [__] uh smells like teen
spirit came on for a while i forget the
other video that i really liked from
nirvana and then [__] uh
when i discovered sound garden
i almost jumped out of [__] window
and then alice in chains and then i was
blessed by being able to move up there
i'm sorry to interrupt whatever i was
talking about but hey i just want to
mention to you that the joint is
sponsored by better help online therapy
listen
if you're like i was you might think
therapy is only for people who are
already off the deep and that's not true
nothing could be further more from the
truth therapy is very
even guys like me
it's the tool that helps us before
things get too bad listen i signed up
with better help maybe uh
seven months ago when i was going
through my uh
little good time there and i'll tell you
dana has done a great job with me
they've done a great job you know i talk
to her once a week it's cheap
it's right there you don't have to go
anywhere i think it's the best there is
so better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and live
chat sessions with your therapist
if you don't want to see anybody you
don't have to
it's too it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 20 48 hours
give it a try it helped me and it worked
it helped two million other people that
have used better help online therapy
we're sponsored by better and joint
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month with betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz and now
back to the joint
you know i went up there to chase a
skirt to do comedy
you know just not knowing that [__]
this is what was going on
around me so once i got up there i got
to listen to mother love bone like i
could tell you guys oh i want to see
more of the level no i didn't no i
didn't i didn't know any of this [__] i
didn't know the history until i moved to
seattle and then you know smoking dope
with people and all that [__] they let
you know like there was a lot of
a lot of [__] grudge historians up
there as you could say you know
everybody everybody knew chris cornell
everybody was personal friends with him
but it didn't matter it was just great
uh
like i wasn't part of that 60 yeah i
like neil young i like
eric clapton i like you know there's a
lot of people in there that the allman
brothers you know all those great
recordings i like led zeppelin
i never got to see them and i never got
to see them blow up from the beginning
you know what i mean like i joined in
when the party had already started in
fact by the time i got into zeppelin
zeppelin had already killed like three
underage girls they already [__] shot
heroin to [__] you know by the time i
got into these bands ac dc by the time i
got into them you know it was power rage
into highway to hell and then bond scott
died
but pearl jam
all these guys i had a [__] is
pro jam 10 pro gems first down
i don't think so but i'm not sure don't
quote me on that but that you know 10
super unknown and
and never mind by nirvana
they [__] rocked my world you know
i'm saying so
it's so weird how i was part of that
like i could consider my like i still
remember going to giggles [__]
comedy club
i used to go to giggles
i don't know every other week and then i
started working every week
but at giggles
this is the weirdest thing there was a
girl i just bought weed from she was a
hippie chick really cute
really attractive you know
she liked me because i was dirty on
stage some of the waitresses thought i
would you know because nobody else
was ballsy enough to get dirty in there
because the owner of the club was a
vietnam vet
and he got shot down on a plane or some
[__]
you know and he didn't want to [__]
he bought the club and he didn't want to
hear
dirty stuff and it was crazy but
i would always go on stage before the
guy got there which gave me you know 45
minutes to be dirty as soon as i saw his
jaguar pull in the window from the stage
think about it [__] had a stage
and a little window on the bottom
so i could see when his car pulled up
and once this car pulled up i would wrap
it up i'd do the five minutes of
knock-knock jokes that i have you know
what animal don't you play cards with a
cheetah
the audience would look at me all
[__] weird and i would get off there
and then but this little waitress well i
would always go on thursday nights
friday nights i had plans afterwards but
like saturdays you hang out with the
staff when you're a comedian
on saturday nights you can hang out with
the staff and on thursday nights since
there's only one show you get out of
there at 10 10 30. you can hang out with
the staff and every time i would get
like reefer from uh i think i also cop
coke from her a couple times she'd
always say to me
if you want we could go up to a [__]
whatever hill
and party out with alice in chains and i
would go what
i was in chains
you know at first i was excited about
i'm like [__] yeah she's like yeah but
the problem is they might shoot heroin i
was like
let's lay off that for right now
it wasn't that i was a [__] or whatever
you guys know i'm in whatever i'm in
through the outdoor
if you have it
run it by me i will i want to do it at
that time do i have plans maybe i had
plans that night and i couldn't put
everyone but they were shooting everyone
i can't listen
i put a needle with heroin in my arm
that'll be the last time you see me guys
that would be it you guys know it's
tough for me to give a [__] blood
test
never mind heroin in my [__] arm so
if she would have said to me yeah they
snort white heroin or whatever you could
just come up hang out ah
something didn't feel right and i got to
tell you something every time i think
how many times she invited me
i want to jump out of a [__] window i
should have just gone up and when they
would have passed the syringe i could
have just shot it behind my neck and i
asked him questions like how did you
write the rooster and all these [__]
great songs you put out but
huh you look back and you go what the
[__] was i thinking you know
but it was really cool you know i had
the opportunity to live there
when i was there ended up going to see
soundgarden
they were not good i cannot lie to you i
know you guys would love
for me to tell you they were great i got
to jump up and down with chris he gave
me a [__] xanax but it wasn't that
type of story
now that i went to see him at the old
improv
if you go to downtown seattle like it's
a [__] weird right by the market
while that market you see on tv it was
right pikes pike speak market whatever
the [__] it's called
bike speed market goes that way if you
cross the street
the old improv was there they changed
the name of it and then if you cross the
street it's deja vu
64 good looking ones three ugly ones so
that was the that was what they said i
don't know three chubby ones i don't
know what the [__] they said
but i had done comedy there a couple of
times at the improv it was not the
improv they changed it to like a music
club
and then uh
after they put out their last studio
album
i forget what it's called in through the
outdoor that's
led zeppelin up the upside it's got
blow up the outside world and it's got
rhinosaur it's got some great [__]
songs on it
they did a little world tour
like on a small tour and they did a show
at the improv and i went
and his voice was gone chris cornell's
voice was gone i was so [__] sad
but it was great to see him they did
rusty cage
he did fell on you know black days they
did all my favorites
the
bass player
or the drummer from soundgarden i think
it's the bass player had a club in
downtown seattle at the time and he
would hang out in a ben shepard
something like that
so josh wolf's lobo loco was just down
the block
from ben sheppard we were walking there
i listen i didn't know nobody in there i
never met ben's [__] but i don't know
nobody i wanted i got a couple beers i
looked around i didn't see anybody i
wanted to hang out with and i abandoned
ship that's what you do i thought you
know my demented drug mind i thought
chris cornell was gonna be down there
hanging out with the boys but there was
no [__] chris cornell there was
nobody
but it was a nice [__] experience for
me living in seattle and uh
you know i think about i haven't been
there since i left when i left seattle i
left seattle
like my [__] was on fire and the well
was in mexico i had to get the [__] out
they gave me like an ultimatum the court
was like you gotta go we'll let you go
but don't come back how's that deal i
was like
tremendous and i abandoned [__]
and i got the [__] out of there and that
was
the end of my seattle days but it was a
good time i became a good comic up there
i learned a lot about comedy
i made friends with josh wolf i became
friends with mitch hedberg
it was uh quite the [__] comedy
experience and it was all
led by music
it's a weird [__] story how did like
when i had the opportunity to follow the
girl up there i was like
seattle and never [__] the sun don't
come out
and i was like wait a second
they got good food
no they got shitty [__] weather
but they got a good music scene
bruce lee's buried up there i gotta go
up there and pay my respects
and if bruce lee's buried up there
that means i gotta have good chinese
food up there
plus i get to hang out with a girl you
know what i'm saying who's better than
me i'm sitting here in boulder snorting
coke in a rocky apartment what am i
gonna do with my life so i took a chance
like columbus i ended up in seattle and
i looked back at it today and it was
[__] dynamite do i want to go back
i miss a piece of salmon from time to
time from this
in fact i used to go to a place to eat
salmon
the only place i would go to well rod
long used to take me to eat salmon
but that's where chris cornell worked
when he was getting soundgarden together
he was a cook and a fish place and now
there's a it's a chain it's like the
mcdonald's of seattle
if anybody uh knows the name please
tweet me the [__] name because i
forget what it was but
yeah those are my memories up there man
i had a great time up there for comedy
you know drove to portland a lot it's
just uh it's a different part of what i
don't know now you got like zones and
[__] you hit in the head black lives
matter the jerky boys you know every two
weeks got a new [__] band every new
week you got a new band up there or new
[__] militia i don't know what's
going on up there anymore but i was
talking to you guys about [__] the
snow this weekend
you know i was even scared to hit mike
up i'm like i'm not gonna see mike for a
couple [__] days there ain't gonna be
no podcast on monday and wednesday this
week there was a lot of [__] snow out
there and there was something that i
hadn't experienced in a long [__]
time
wind
with snow you don't think i went out
there on saturday night i went out there
to smoke dope
with the [__] pipe dog i couldn't do
it there was no way you
[__] the
smokey the fireman what's his name
smokey the bear
couldn't light the [__]
bong out there that night i'm all out
there trying to hit it and i'll tell you
it wasn't the wind the wind was coming
in with like [__] snow hitting in the
face i hadn't had that [__] since i
robbed that liquor store since i robbed
that jewelry store in colorado
i haven't been beat up by the snow like
that and i was out there you know i went
out there
saturday morning
i was getting to this before and i got
distracted these [__]
cheech and chung tummy [__] bread
strips
they're doing the trick today for 20 but
guess what
we might as well kick it up to 30. what
i'm saying
it's monday what do you think that mikey
[__]
you guys want to party we got a little
[__] party we can't smoke upstairs
because i don't i can't smoke down here
because of the family
but an edible
it's always good you know what i'm
saying it's too early for an abx-200 i'm
excited i'm getting a new [__] dose
of abx
sleep and stuff they got a new thing
like for my wife they're like
10 milligrams
but with a lot of sleep in it cbd
and a lot more cbn and cby so just
giving you a heads up [__]
that's part of my job to let you know
what's coming out in the weird world in
the world of [__] marijuana and get
yourself nice and tuned up
oh
yeah
it's sharp
and your mouth is dry
but then it melts
and it's chocolate mint like one of
those [__] bars one of those
commercials you eat the ball and your
hair blows back now
i don't know
whatever the [__] the mint did
but it was funny last week
saturday morning when i woke up it was
[__] a disaster out there
i started both cars my wife came out
my wife is worried about me shoveling
snow and i'm worried about my wife she's
no [__] spring chicken either so we
made a deal so she blows the snow blower
and i clean around with the shovel
around the ends
i'll tell you it was [__] cold the
first time i went out there lasted like
10 minutes because i couldn't breathe
it was just it was just overwhelming
that the wind and [__]
and i went back out then i polished off
the steps i polished off the [__]
sides
and my wife looked at me she's like
[__] you're pretty good at shoveling
snuggle [__]
i did this [__] for a long [__] time
i lived in boulder and aspen and
snowmass when you live in those places
you become a [__] snow shoveler
within days you just become a
professional you know how to warm up
your car correctly you don't you know my
wife's out there trying to scrape the
glass i'm like timeout start the [__]
car first let it get hot and watch the
snow just [__] melt off the goddamn
car and she's like oh my god i don't
lost like lit both cars up we got all
plugged up with the [__] snow blower
she paid a buck and a quarter for this
snow blower you got to see this
[__]
yeah but my buddy down the corner got
one for 8.50 like you see is that
[__] oh my god
so i i thought it was like three grand
the one he had he goes nah i lifted the
rock for 850. so i said listen how about
i lift the rock for a 20 and you do my
front of my house we started laughing
[__] he did that he did the street in
front of my house because it's too much
the plows hadn't even came by that man
come like at two in the morning it was
[__]
nine in the morning and it was
it was snowing like [__] an inch and
a half an hour it was coming down it was
really [__] coming down it was
beautiful guys was it cold that i freeze
i lose a finger
no it was [__] tremendous it's always
good for you to go out there and shovel
a little snow and breathe that [__]
cold there i had my boo i had boots that
i my wife got me for christmas two years
ago i never put them on
till this week now i won't take them off
they feel tremendous they don't smell
yet oh my feet are nice and warm i went
out there today with these [__]
i went to the gym today and i walked on
the treadmill for 20 minutes i almost
had a [__] heart attack but i had to
get done quickly because the gym was
closed and i want to meet mike and do
the podcast
but who the [__] knows what i'm talking
about when we were shoveling yesterday
after my wife said that to me
i remember i was shoveling the
sidewalk and it was just a straight path
i just would pick it up and then
and she came by and knocked it off but
it was so funny i was thinking about
me being a [__] and we know when i say
it guys
i know you guys think it's a joke
but it's [__] sad
i was a [__] snow shoveler
because they started i just i took a
chance i was working for an electrician
it was getting cold
the guy that i hit with the stick at the
electrical job i finally because he
[__]
tried to get me with a knife i hit him
with the stick and then he took off so
aspirin electric was kind of falling
apart
the guy was going down to one crew and i
was like you know what it's like
everything else
it's like the man said bill hicks
it sounded great on paper but once i
smoked pop and slept on it i didn't feel
like taking a bus to aspen every day
and then once i would take a bus to
aspen i would have to walk like a half a
mile
meet the electricians load the truck and
then we would drive another hour and a
half into the hills of [__] colorado
or south colorado or glenwood springs
and beyond
bonedale and [__] there's only one road
to do it on you know what it was
exciting work like everything else you'd
do at first but after a while you're
like what am i dropping a [__] lunch
what am i dropping in bus fares every
[__] day i don't get home till seven
and some guy by my house said listen we
just do electrical [__] on [__] no
construction none of that locally his
name was jaeger
electrician i love greg yeager good
[__]
so he's like look i'll pay you like 12
10 an hour and do this [__] with me four
or five hours a day i said why not so i
helped him out
like towards after thanksgiving in the
first couple weeks of december and one
day i was at the city market and i saw a
sign snow shovel is needed
called joe coffee i was like what
joe coffee is my [__] neighbor he
lives in sea building i lived in d
building so i knocked on his door and
i'm like [__] i want a snow shelter's
job just stay in shape to be outside i
would do the electrician part-time i
would do the snow shoveling part-time
and i would ski part-time i knew i was
coming home in february i just wanted to
make extra [__] scratch
but while i'm there i'm like holy [__]
this is a perfect job i get this come
outside breathe i got my walkman i could
smoke dope he wouldn't say anything for
me to smoke smoking joke dope joe coffee
and
i could case all the [__] buildings
here
it was building c d
c
e f g
h
there were six buildings and there had
to be
seven drug dealers voila
i'm not going anywhere
and these are the dumbest drug dealers
in the world because i like to ski
listen if i got a half a [__] pound
of coke in my house
either my grandmother lives with me oh i
don't ski do you understand me
yeah i'm from that [__] school that's
why all dealers always have their mother
living with them or grandpa they don't
even know they're living in a drug house
you don't say nothing to them you just
put them in the bedroom pay for their
[__] groceries and pay their rent
they think they're living in utopia no
they're not you buy them a nice tv and
you put them in the front of the house
by your window
and people think that they watch tv all
day
you guys never thought about this come
on guys
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with joey bananas but that's how we do
it these dumb [__] just oh
let's go skiing i would watch them get
in that car i would watch them put the
skis i would watch them forget [__] and
go back up but once i knew they were
gone
i knew they weren't coming back for four
or three hours they were going to ski
for two and then drink on the hill for
one you know what i can do in your house
in three hours i can paint your house by
the time you come back it'll be painted
and robbed who's better than uncle joe i
could rob your house and then paint like
a door
like that would have been good if i
could do it all over again that's what i
do i paint the door and really [__] with
them like how they know to paint my door
i never asked anybody to paint my door
but there's also an ounce of coke
missing
so every day every [__] day i would
go out there early there was a couple of
drug dealers that were like part-time
shuttle drivers
and they stopped by the house every 20
minutes to check on their house to do a
line of coke
and i would watch them get in that
shovel and then they would go deep over
the hill i'd go right over there my
friend made me a [__] jimmy burkle
god rest his soul
he took a [__] one of those hand saws
it's like a little handsaw he had
the blade was maybe 18 inches this
[__] took it in the house one
night he was my roommate from north
bergen straight up gangsta died a few
years back i always let a candle from um
on mondays
i want to be around to pick up the
pieces anyway he took the [__] door
he took it off the hinges and he
measured it just right he figured out
how to make the two go in now we had the
same front door
as
c
f e g and h
it was like a [__] no-brainer
and now you're looking at me going joey
you're a creepy [__] sucker no i'm
telling you the truth and i'm also
telling you if you move into one of
those complexes make sure you change
your [__] lot
because
if you're in that complex everybody got
the same lock as you do you dumb
[__] you never thought about
that
everybody got the same luck that means
that there's a master it opens up all of
them you don't want that so after you
move in you don't even say nothing to
the landlord you change that [__]
lock so if you live in [__]
susquehanna apartments
and there's like a b c d
and you don't want people to rob you
change the [__] front lock and now
your lock is completely different from
everybody else's
nobody else thought about that [__] even
the [__] smarter drug dealers with
their [__] yuppy minds and their rich
dads it took a little street little
demon like uncle joey to go give me that
[__] tool and all i had to do they
wouldn't even lock the top lock
why but oh i always had a plan for the
back door you follow me so if my tool
went through the front door and you
didn't top the top lock if you didn't
lock the top lock then i was [__] but
never fear uncle joey's here i would
walk around the back and unzip your
[__]
that's why i always close my screen gate
with a double [__] security because
you'll be back there longer
you'll be exposed longer
i know that a [__] kid could break
through that screen door
but if you go to pull it one time it's
got two different locks that leaves you
at that lock for a longer time which
means people drive by
and they'll see you in my backyard do
you understand me
i [__] created the security in this
[__] house i'm the one that had the
cameras come over i told him how to put
the cameras and the doors when we moved
here took us like three months my wife's
like well are you gonna get adp we got
adp plus
because i know how to deter a
[__] burglar how do i know
because i was a [__] burglar i knew
it busted my chops and i would sit there
and go how are people not
looking over this especially when you
have drugs in your house
when you got drugs in your house you got
cash in your house your house has to be
[__] secure these guys wouldn't
lock the top lock you know how many of
them
always left the back screen door open
i say 40 percent and i'll tell you the
percentage for a window in a bathroom
90 percent
nobody ever closes the bathroom window
have you ever [__] thought about that
nobody people go in there open it up let
the steam out you close it but anyway
i'm not teaching you how to be a [__]
burglar i'm just letting you know how to
counter
securitize your home you understand me
another thing you didn't think you get
from uncle joy but all those little
things would leave me out there longer
these people never thought like that
they never thought to put a table in
front of the back door why i got to push
it you're still going to get in
but it buys time it buys time for one of
your neighbors
to see this jerk off in your backyard or
your front door you come to my front
door you're gonna have 19 distractions
you got the people across the street you
got the chinese people to the side you
got the cop behind the [__] house you
got the pumas across the street i got
eyes on my house the same way i watched
these [__] but back then people
weren't doing that god forbid i got a
kilo of coke in here are you [__]
kidding me
i don't even put bob white on the
[__]
on the [__]
what do you call that [__] the chimney
santa thinks he's gonna make an early
[__]
drop into my chimney i chopped that
chubby [__] up
but anyway who the [__] the [__] am i
talking about it's monday morning it's
the 31st of january we did it we got to
the first month of 2022 it was a success
some of us got sick some of us didn't
but guess what
we're here [__] and that's all
that matters it's monday [__]
you're getting a second chance to be a
[__] savage so take it fill out your
goals write your [__] journal out and
get out there and be the best you that
you can be that's what i'm trying to do
i'm not trying to sell tickets i don't
want to do dick i'm just trying to go to
jiu jitsu a couple days a week finish my
[__] book
and move on with my [__] life
what am i gonna do do i have a sketch i
got nothing i got nothing i'm just
living life enjoying it in southern
[__] new jersey i'm giving
chinese food a break i put on like 10
pounds
it's just the holidays and i can't
[__] take it i work all i work myself
the doctor in a week
walking on the treadmill doing this
so i decided me and my wife were talking
the other day we're like
last time i had chinese i didn't feel
good that and this is great chinese food
it's great chinese food it's clean i've
never gotten sick off the pork there i
get the [__] szechuan
uh twice cooked pork holy [__]
it's so [__] delicious
but anyway that's my plans for now uh
february i'm doing a couple things don't
forget the eighth of february the grammy
state theater in new york hari's doing
his renamed
storytellers show i do not know if i'm
gonna be there
it's the 31st i haven't even opened the
notebook i'm still working on
finishing the book we got maybe
four more chapters left on the [__]
book
guys
it took me eight to ten years
to write the [__] outline
we have written the book
myself and erica florentine
in a [__] year i am
listen i don't know if the book's gonna
be any good i don't know if it's gonna
be bad
i don't give a [__]
i mean the publishers will clean it up
and they have editors and all that stuff
and it's going to be a great book you
understand what i'm saying to you but in
my world it was just a goal to do
so last year even though i was
withdrawing
even though i had the knee surgery even
though i wasn't doing much but a podcast
i [__] put together a book and it was
hard work man you gotta
you gotta think you gotta outline at
night you know
it's not just it's like a [__] two
hours at night for me to do that i gotta
get i gotta think
i gotta make phone calls i gotta look at
my imdb
it's [__] rough to you know kick up
the the memories especially you know
what we were doing on the church we were
[__] killing our memory i don't
remember
[__] it's just starting to come back to
me
and this little time i've had the last
three months has been great
because i've been unwinding and making
little [__] notes and going wow
i should have caught this then i should
have taken care of this then but hey
life is life we're done the only thing
that matters today
it's monday i'm looking over here [__]
it's like a battlefield we destroyed
chong clay how many you eat three three
and i ate three two so that's 30 a piece
that's [__] [__] but it's early you
know what i'm saying and we got a couple
more to finish
and that's it and that's that guys tommy
chung's
chocolate mint i love everything about
him he did a nice package he's taking
care like i said i like that to
individually wrap because if you get
them like in the old ones yeah they
would give you 500 when you 500
milligrams so let's say five of them but
after you took one and you put it in
your wallet the other four would
melt into one now you were forced to
either take the whole one
or cut it in half
and you know in our world we just take
the whole one why [__] around you
understand me
so that's it and that's that guys
it's a [__] monday morning [__]
wrap-a-thon
i don't know where i got the energy
today but i got it i'm feeling good i'm
looking good i'm talking to joe about
going down in february
uh ahri's thing we got the weed release
tomorrow the first at the ice cream cake
goes
try out the white truffle
i'm talking about king condom to maybe
sponsor her podcast with laughing gas
and george perez's so we got [__] going
on guys i love you [__] with
all my heart
we'll be back wednesday but hey it's
[__] monday the 31st of the month
perfect day for you [__] write
your goals for february
get your journal going get your dick
sucked it's all gonna be a good month
manscape valentine's day ball sucking
february is always [__] great i love
you [__] with all my heart
have a great day and i'll see you
wednesday the 2nd
which is going to be 2 2
22.
how [__] creepy is that [__] i
love you
stay black have a great day and i'll see
you wednesday and now for a word my
[__] sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening today
it's a beautiful day to be alive and if
you want to make your day a little bit
more beautiful the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy listen nobody
wants to go to therapy everybody thinks
that you know you got to be off the deep
end but you're wrong
therapy is for everybody it's a tool
that helps us before things get too bad
in my situation my anxiety was killing
me
i couldn't focus i didn't know what else
to do
i
contacted betterhelp.com they connected
me with dana
in fact i got to pick her out told her
what my problems were you you fill out
the
initial forms
and next thing you know within a day or
two
there i was with dana helping me and
that was about seven eight months ago
and here we are today better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist listen i loved it
i had a great time doing it i learned a
lot about myself
it's much more affordable and in person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in under 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we're sponsored by betterhelp
and joint listeners i'm going to give
you 10
off your first month when you go to
betterhelp.com again
that's b b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
[Music]
dot-com
slash diaz set yourself free
and the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion the best
when it comes to cbd i only trust listen
i've tried a bunch of them and cbd lion
has been coming through for me
for about three to four years whether
it's uh the tape
the tincture is tremendous
the gummy bears are second to none the
melatonin gummy bears to help you rest
cbd has a lot of use uses they're saying
cbd can help now with the cold video
situations i don't know i'm not a doctor
go to cbdlion.com
read the fine print
read all about cbd cbn and how it could
help you
press and joey at checkout and get 20
off whether it's joey or joint or church
they'll take care
i also want to thank draftkings the best
the official sports betting partner
of the the super bowl
in honor of the big game draftking
sports
is giving you 56 to one odds
where are you gonna get that action that
means if you bet five dollars you win
280 and free bets if your team wins
who's better than you and draftkings
sportsbook is now live in new york that
means you could put a betting from
buffalo to [__] canarsie and
you can bet from anywhere and the third
of the country is what if
the draftking sports book isn't in your
state yet well guess what
draftkings daily fantasy is and they got
daily contests a special one for super
bowl 56 new customers get a free shot at
a million dollar top prize with their
first deposit what are your chances of
making a million
get on download the draftkings
daily fantasy football contest for super
bowl 56 and get 56 to one odds on either
team bet five dollars
and win 280 and free bets that's promo
code joey
and draftking sportsbook download the
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56 now you got to be 21 older
minimum age and location requirements
vary by just the
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for full list of requirements
and state specific responsible gaming
resources voidware prohibited if you got
a gam problem call 1800 gambler
if you're in tennessee call
1-800-889-9789
if you're in connecticut 888
and if you're in new york
call 8778 hope new york but if you got
no problems it's time to download that
[__] app and let's get this
party started you got mba you got
college basketball and you got the super
bowl stay black have a great monday and
i'll see you guys wednesday
so
[Music]
you